hi i'm kanchan khoya the founder of
spice spice baby and i love curry it's
dreamy it's creamy it's packed with
spices you can put whatever you want in
it and i think anyone should be able to
have curry anytime they want so today
i'm going to be showing you how to make
a three minute curry a 30 minute curry
and a three hour curry so let's get
started
say you only have three minutes but you
really want curry with as much of the
flavor as possible this recipe is for
you it's probably going to offend some
curry aficionados but we're going to be
okay with that in the name of efficiency
first we're going to create our curry
sauce by using coconut cream one of the
things i love about curry is the creamy
texture which is kind of challenging to
achieve in three minutes so the coconut
cream instead of coconut milk really
helps us do that we're gonna add onion
powder garlic powder and ginger powder
one of the things i love about curry is
that you get to layer aromatics like
onion garlic and ginger and oil but
since we only have three minutes we're
just gonna hack that by adding the
powders instead then we're gonna add
cayenne for heat then we add some
turmeric garam masala for those smoky
notes cumin and coriander powder now
we're going to add salt to taste
and some black pepper
mix this all together
sure is easier than cooking a curry on
the stove for hours finally we're gonna
add our canned chickpeas that have been
well rinsed and drained and now we're
just gonna cover this now we're gonna
put this in the microwave for three
minutes until it's hot and all those
amazing flavors have had some time to
get to know each other curry in a hurry
that smells really good so now we're
just gonna take off the cling wrap and
marvel at the fact that we just made
curry in three minutes we're just gonna
stir in some chopped spinach so it's
gonna wilt down quicker a hit of lime
juice for those citrusy flavor notes and
then we're just gonna mix this all
together
my mom would be really impressed with
this hack it truly smells like the real
deal i'm not even gonna lie we're gonna
spoon it onto some steamed rice we're
gonna hit it with some fresh cilantro
for vibrancy and we're gonna taste it
this is shockingly delicious i can taste
the citrus all the spices the different
notes the creaminess from the coconut
for three minutes this tastes like a
legit curry this is great for busy
weeknights when you want to make
something your kids are going to lap up
even if your indian mother-in-law would
not approve say you want something a bit
more authentic and you have a little bit
more time this next 30-minute recipe is
just for you
while most people are familiar with
north indian curry recipes this
particular one is inspired by southern
india and while i'm technically north
indian i have to say this is one of my
favorites we're going to start by
warming our coconut oil on medium heat
to which we're going to add our mustard
seeds and we're going to allow these to
sizzle and even splatter a little bit
it's going to wake up the spices and add
so much flavor and now we're going to
toss in our curry leaves just as those
curry leaves are starting to crisp up
about 30 seconds or so we're gonna add
our green chilies the green chili is
gonna add spice it's totally optional
but come on and then we're gonna add our
sliced onions and give that all a nice
toss smells so good
this combination of mustard seeds curry
leaves and oil can be drizzled on your
favorite salad on soups and really on
anything it is a classic base for most
southern indian dishes i'm going to let
these onions cook down until soft for
about five minutes
now that my onions have softened i'm
gonna add a tablespoon of minced ginger
and four cloves of minced garlic and
just allow that to cook until fragrant
you definitely don't want to burn it
once you can smell that ginger and
garlic and it smells so good we're going
to add in two teaspoons of tandoori
masala so i am cheating a little with
the tandoori spice blend because this is
a 30 minute weeknight friendly curry
once you can start to smell that spice
blend it's time to add the tomatoes the
tomatoes are not just going to add a
sauce but they're also gonna give us
these beautiful tangy notes at this
point we're gonna let this cook for
about three minutes and while these are
cooking you may be wondering how can
this be a curry when it doesn't have
curry powder let's talk about that we
don't really have a thing called curry
powder curry is such a broad concept in
india it really varies from family to
family region to region and that's why
i'm not adding just straight curry
powder to this but it's still very much
a curry now that our spiced curry base
is done we're going to add some chopped
chicken you can do any kind of protein
like fish or you could also go
completely plant-based and do chickpeas
again we're going to hit this with salt
pepper
i'm just gonna toss this chicken to get
it well coated with the spice mixture
and until it's no longer pink and then
we're gonna add the coconut milk some
tamarind paste
and sugar this is looking creamy i can
smell the tamarind and the aroma and the
smoky notes from that spice blend this
is going to be good we're just going to
cover this on medium heat and let it
cook for about 15 minutes until the
chicken is cooked through it's been 15
minutes and i am just transported back
to my childhood i can smell those spices
and the coconut and i just want to dive
in we're just gonna spoon this over
plain steamed rice we're gonna hit it
with fresh cilantro again because that's
just what we do and because i like heat
i'm gonna do a little sprinkling of
chili powder totally optional unless
you're me
a little bit more people think curry is
so complicated but it's really just
about layering flavor adding a little
bit of this a little bit of that and
this is the result i cannot wait to try
it
don't burn your mouth
oh
that is so good like a hug in a bowl
comfort food at its best we have the
sweetness from the little bit of sugar
we have the tang from the tomatoes and
the tamarind we have all those smoky
notes from the spices a little bit of
heat it is really a party in the mouth
so i've shown you two pretty quick and
straightforward curry recipes but say
you want to really up your game impress
your guests this next recipe is gonna
blow their minds
while our 30-minute recipe took
inspiration from the southern part of
india today we're gonna be making rogan
josh a traditional kashmiri meat curry
here we have some cubed beef to which
we're gonna add garam masala spice blend
and sea salt give it a good toss to coat
the meat with the spices garam masala is
very often used in many indian dishes
particularly in northern indian curries
it has smoky notes from clove cinnamon
cardamom bay leaf black pepper and a
host of other really mesmerizing spices
and it goes so well with any meat dish
now we're going to brown the beef in
batches without overcrowding the pan
until it is nice and brown on all sides
coating the beef in the garam masala
really allows us to get that layering of
flavor now that my beef is nice and
brown i'm going to take it out on a
sheet pan where it can rest don't
discard anything from the pan it has all
the flavor and all the juices from the
beef and now we're going to use that to
saute our onions i'm going to add a
little salt to the onions to season as i
go and to help them soften a little bit
quicker i'm just gonna saute these
onions until they're soft for about five
minutes some people like to really get
the onions nice and golden brown do
whatever feels right for you it's all a
personal preference our onion is nice
and softened even a little brown to that
we're gonna add our ginger and garlic
you can start to see that a lot of
curries have this kind of onion ginger
garlic in oil base in common now that
the ginger and garlic is nice and
fragrant i'm going to add my whole
spices i'm adding black peppercorns
green and black cardamom some whole
cloves
a cinnamon stick dried red chilies and
bay leaves we're going to saute these
whole spices with the onion ginger
garlic mixture for just about a minute
until nice and toasted and fragrant and
then we're going to add our turmeric red
pepper
cumin coriander
fennel powder and some dry fenugreek
leaves sauteing the spices at the
beginning of the curry as a base here is
really activating the flavor a lot of
the volatile compounds and just waking
up those spices so unlike the earlier
dish where we use the pre-existing
tandoori blend here we're really
building our own rogan josh spice blend
our spices are toasted and beautifully
aromatic and now we're going to add back
our browned beef so because spices have
antibacterial properties they were used
back in the day to prevent meat from
spoiling almost like a pre-refrigeration
refrigeration hack so we're getting the
beef all nice and coated with the spice
mixture and then to this we are going to
add some whipped yogurt some people now
actually add tomato to rogan josh for
tang we're going with greek yogurt
now that the beef is nicely coated with
that spiced yogurt mixture we're just
gonna add enough water to cover
salt and pepper
now we're just gonna let this cook low
and slow for two and a half hours until
that beef is nice and tender and all the
flavors have merged beautifully together
now that our rogan josh is simmering
away we're gonna make roti roti or
indian flatbread is a staple in every
house while it can seem intimidating you
and me were in this together and we're
gonna figure it out so first we're gonna
add whole wheat flour half a cup of warm
water a little bit of oil
and some salt so i'm just gonna toss
everything together and then i'm going
in with my hands so you wanna knead this
until the dough comes together
and does not stick to your fingers if
your dough is a little sticky just add a
little bit more flour my dough has now
come together i'm just going to let this
rest for 30 minutes under this damp
towel and we'll be back now that our
dough has rested it's time to roll out
the roti so we're just going to take a
little piece with our hands you don't
have to be super precise here you're
going to make a little ball
and then sprinkle your surface with
flour so it doesn't stick coat my little
circle with flowers so it's easier to
roll and then we roll roll a little bit
turn a little bit
roll
turn
roll turn that should get you to a
perfect circle if your dinner guests
judge you for your roti not being a
perfect circle
i think you should send them home this
is a great activity to get your kids
involved in sensory skill building
resilience building because it's not
gonna be a circle they're gonna have to
be okay with failure this looks great so
i'm gonna set this guy aside and roll
out the rest now it's time to cook the
rotis the trick here is to get the pan
scorching hot almost to the point where
it's uncomfortable to place your hand
right above it we're gonna place the
rotis in the hot dry skillet for about
two minutes you want your roti to puff
up but if it doesn't don't worry about
it it's gonna taste just as good so i'm
just gonna flip it i'm gonna let this go
for another 30 seconds to a minute okay
and then we're just going to top it with
a little bit of butter
for extra moisture and deliciousness
that's our first roti i'm going to cook
up the rest and once that's done we're
going to be ready to bring our roti and
curry together
so our roti is done our rogan josh is
done let's bring it all together i'm
totally plating a whole red chili
because i will eat it as always a little
garnish of cilantro so i'm just gonna go
right in using the roti almost as a
spoon to pick up my succulent beef rogan
josh
i can taste those rich and warm spices
the succulent beef the tangy yogurt the
roti is just perfect to soak up all
those flavors this is the ultimate
comfort food three hours may seem like a
lot of time to make a dish but trust me
this rogan josh is worth it so there you
have it three curries in three different
amounts of time we have the three-minute
microwave curry for when you want curry
in a hurry we have a 30-minute curry for
when you want a really delicious meal on
a week night and then we have a
three-hour curry for when you really
want to impress someone special i hope
you make them all and let me know which
one is your favorite in the comments
below i'm kanchan and there's always
time for curry oh yes
[Music]
[Music]
you